there is a mass exodus out of russia but
it's not so easy to see
we'd come to a street in istanbul to
find two of the many russians on the run
tania simekova edits a lifestyle website
but when it was blocked by authorities
last week she knew she and her partner
had to flee the country
it's like german with hitler
right now
and
everyone
are so
horrible terrified by putin they are so
afraid of him
new fake news laws criminalize
independent journalism in russia making
tanya's job very dangerous
i think they
will take me to the prison
for 15 years
and
just so simple in russia do you think
the fsb they're in shock at what their
government is doing and deeply worried
about friends and family in russia but
also ukraine
i feel desperate and i
i hate them so much
i don't i do not know how to tell it and
uh
i'm trying not to cry and uh
and my ukrainian colleagues and my
relatives and odessa you know
they just
are you in touch with them are you
talking to them yeah yeah what are they
saying
they're just alive and that's the point
an estimated 200 000 russians have left
since the invasion of ukraine seeking
sanctuary abroad many coming here to
antalya where they've been welcomed for
years
but finding those willing to talk isn't
easy so we've just met a russian family
in an estate agents who decided less
than a week ago that the mood in moscow
had turned so ugly that they had to get
out as soon as possible so they've told
friends and family they're here in
turkey on holiday but they're trying to
get property and they won't be going
back now he's not an activist he's not a
journalist he's a fishmonger but he says
he's had so many threats he has no
choice but to get his wife and
nine-year-old daughter out and he says
it would be too dangerous to talk on
camera this is your mia card yeah this
is sir our russian payments those
already here say in the last two weeks
life has become harder their currency
plunging in value their nation becoming
a pariah when i'm going outside from my
home i feel uh not
how to say i feel not so comfortable now
because i'm russian because i'm have
russian passport because
mostly people don't understand that uh
the
the war it's not from our russian people
we can't smile
like before because when i sit here and
when i try to smile sometimes i think
that i cannot i have no rights to do it
whatever the challenges abroad it will
be easier than life in the motherland
and many more are likely to follow
draining russia of its best and
brightest dominic waghorn sky news
antalya